[Music]
Okay. Hey everyone. Uh I'm Jerry,
co-founder, CEO of Llama Inducts. It's
great to be here. Um and today my topic
uh the talk title is building AI agents
that actually automate knowledge work.
So basically a big promise of AI agents
these days is making knowledge workers
more efficient. Um I'm I'm sure you've
heard the like highlevel business speak
of this. Um and I copy and pasted a
bunch of B2B SAS vendors on the on the
right in terms of screenshots. You know
increase operational efficiency better
decision-m through more data. But what
does this actually mean right does
knowledgework automation actually just
mean building rag chat bots? and if not
what is the stack and what are the use
cases that AI agents can actually do um
in terms of automating knowledge work.
So for us a lot of our use cases and a
lot of our core focus areas is basically
automating knowledge work over
unstructured data. Um 90% of enterprise
data lives within the form of documents
whether it is PDFs, powerpoints, um word
and uh you know as you'll soon see Excel
but humans uh have historically needed
to basically read and write these types
of docs right you have you know
investment banker or someone you know
kind of on the customer support side
reviewing a lot of just unstructured
data and using that documentation to
basically make decisions and take
actions. For the first time, AI agents
can actually reason and act over massive
amounts of unstructured context tokens
and you know do analysis, do research,
syn synthesize these insights and
actually take actions end to end.
And so for us when we think about the
use cases and the types of agents for
automating knowledge work, they really
fall into two main categories. There's
what we call assist of agents. Um so
those that are kind of more like a
standard chat interface. They help
humans get more information faster. And
then there's automation type agents.
Agents that automate routine tasks uh
can run in the background, maybe require
a little bit less human in the loop, and
can take actions um that automate the
routine operational stuff. When we think
about the stack that's required to
actually build either the assistive or
automation type agents, there's two main
components. There's really really nice
tools um and then there's a really nice
agent architecture. uh with MCP 80A
these days, a lot of people are thinking
about how do I build really nice tools
that allow agents to interface with the
external world to basically surface
relevant context and let the agent take
uh external actions. And a lot of the
agent architecture, you know, there's
very general reasoning loops as well as
well as more constrained loops. It's
basically how do I encode the business
logic um through an agentic workflow to
help achieve the task.
So for the purposes of this talk, we'll
talk about three main things. Um, a lot
of stuff to cover, so I'll probably pick
up my clock speed a little bit, but
basically there's building a document
toolbox. Um, which is how do I build
really nice tools that allow uh, you
know, AI agents to interact with massive
amounts of unstructured documents. Um,
two is agent design patterns. Um, so
thinking about just at a high level the
two categories of agents from assistance
to automation and three is bringing it
together in terms of document agent use
cases. So first step is on building a
document toolbox.
Basically if you think about agents
interacting with tools um and as LLMs
get better you're going to have these
very general front-end interfaces like
cloud or chatbt um agents need access to
the right tools to basically interface
with the external world. And for the
purposes of you know massive amounts of
unstructured enterprise data um they
basically need the right toolbox to
interact with this data. It's basically
a generalization beyond naive rag,
right? Rag is just uh retrieval. I know
this is a rag workshop. Um but nag rag
is just like retrieval and then oneshot
synthesis. Um a lot of what agents can
do over your documents includes
retrieval but also includes other
operations like filebased search uh
manipulation and more. And one of the
points I'm trying to make is that to
basically create these tool interfaces
in the first place, you need a really
nice pre-processing layer. Um, so you
need, you know, actual data connectors
to your data sources, um, that basically
sync data from your data source into a
format that your agents can access. Um,
you know, could be SharePoint, Google
Drive, S3, Confluence. It needs to sync
permissions to and the right metadata.
You need the right document parsing and
extraction piece. More on this in just a
bit, but you basically need actual
actually good understanding over your
documents, over tables, charts, and
more. And of course, you know, if you
have a large collection of docs and you
needed to index it in some way, um it
could be vector indexing into, you know,
vector search. It could also be uh
indexing into a SQL table. Uh it could
be graph DBs, uh it could be anything.
So basically to ensure the data is high
quality, you need this layer to actually
process andru structure your documents
and expose the right tool interfaces. In
terms of the right tool interfaces, this
is what I want to kind of uh define a
term. It's basically called like a
document MCP server. Um again it's like
a generalization of this idea of rag,
right? If rag is just oneshot vector
retrieval. You kind of need like a set
of tools um to basically equip an AI
agent with uh to basically uh understand
and manipulate different types of
documents. It could be you know doing
semantic search to fuzzy find the
relevant source of data. It could be
file lookup to basically look up the
right file metadata. Um it could be
manipulation to actually do operations
on top of the files and it could be
structure quering right quering a more
structured database to get aggregate
insights over the types of data um that
that you've extracted out.
One, you know, top consideration uh when
actually building this type of toolbox
is uh complex documents. Uh for those of
you who follow our socials, we talk a
lot about this type of issue where a lot
of human knowledge in the form of like
really complicated PDFs and other
formats too. Embedded tables, charts,
images, irregular layouts, headers,
footers. This is typically stuff that's
designed for human consumption and not
machine consumption. And so, you know,
if the documents are not processed
correctly, no matter how good your LLM
is, um it will fail.
So we were probably one of the first
people to actually realize that LLMs and
LVMs could be used for document
understanding. Um if uh in contrast to
more traditional techniques where you
use kind of like hand-tuned and task
specific ML models to achieve uh kind of
like document parsing over a specific
class of documents, LLMs actually have a
much general layer of accuracy um that
you can use to your advantage and just
like understanding and inhaling any type
of document with comp uh any type of
complexity. Um obviously the baseline
these days is you can just screenshot a
PDF, feed it into chatbt or claude. um
it doesn't actually give you amazing
accuracy, but it's a good start. And so
one of the kind of secret sauce like uh
magic tricks we found was figuring out
how to interle LLMs and LVMs with more
traditional parsing techniques and
adding kind of test time tokens in terms
of agentic validation and reasoning to
really get a higher level of accuracy.
Um and so you know we have a cloud
service that does document parsing and
is a core step of this document toolbox.
uh we basically benchmarked uh our modes
where we adapt uh you know sauna 3.5 4.0
uh Gemini 2.5 Pro 4.1 from OpenAI and it
basically outperforms all existing
parsing benchmarks um and and tools out
there in terms of open source to
proprietary um yeah
so some of you might know us as a rag
framework that's basically how we
started um you know for those of you who
don't know we have this uh managed
platform that is basically this GI
native document toolbox um contains a
lot of operations that you need to do on
top of your docs it could be doc
document parsing, document extraction,
uh, uses some of those, you know, kind
of capabilities I just mentioned and
allows you to parse, extract index data
for all the set of tools I just
mentioned.
One of the special releases I actually
want to highlight today um, and we just
announced this in a blog post a few
hours ago is Excel capabilities to help
complement this document toolbox. A lot
of knowledge work happens in Microsoft
Excel and also Google Sheets and, you
know, numbers and basically it's
spreadsheets, right? but it's been
unsolved by LLMs. Um, if you look at the
document to the right, uh, neither rag
nor Texas CSV techniques will actually
work over this because it's not really a
structured 2D table. There's a bunch of
gaps in the rows and gaps in the
columns.
So, we basically built an Excel agent um
that's capable of taking unnormalized
Excel spreadsheets and transforming them
um into a normalized 2D format and also
allows you to do a gentic QA um over uh
both the unnormalized and normalized
versions of the Excel spreadsheet. Um
it's a pretty cool capability. I'll
describe uh how it kind of works in just
a bit. um but it's going to complement
our toolbox right in terms of uh more
traditional document parsing,
extraction, indexing and it's available
in uh early preview. So if you just uh
take a look at the video, it's also on
our blog post. We basically uploaded
that example synthetic data set,
transformed it into a 2D table, and you
can also ask questions over it to
basically get insights. And it's really
doing the heavy lifting of deeply
understanding the semantic structure of
the Excel spreadsheet. Um, and then
using that and plugging that in as
specialized tools to an AI agent.
Um, the best baseline is not really rag
or text to CSV. Um, those both suck. Um,
it's really just an LLM being able to
write code. Um, so LLM with the code
interpreter tool is a reasonable
baseline. Gets you to 70 75% accuracy.
Um, over like a private data set of
synthetic Excel sheets, uh, we basically
were able to get this up to 95%. Um, it
actually surpasses human baselines of
90% of a human trying to go and do the
data transformation by hand.
Um, a brief note on how it works. Uh,
it's a little bit technical. Um but you
know more details are in the blog post.
Um first we do some sort of structure
understanding of the Excel spreadsheet.
So we do a little bit of RL
reinforcement learning. Um you know we
actually kind of adapt dynamically to
the specific format of the document um
and learn a semantic map of the sheet.
By learning a semantic map uh we can
then translate this into um kind of a
set of specialized tools that you
provide to an agent. And so from a
abstract perspective, you can kind of
think about it as an agent could just
write code from scratch. Um as LLMs get
better, that will certainly become um an
e like a a kind of higher performing
baseline. But in the meantime, we're
helping it out by really providing uh a
set of specialized tools over the
semantic map so you can reason over an
Excel spreadsheet.
Great. Um the next piece here is so we
talked about a document toolbox. uh we
talked about a lot of operations
basically make this uh document toolbox
really good and comprehensive. So now
that you plugged it into an agent, what
are the different agent architectures
and what are the use cases are implied
by them? Um as many of you probably know
from building agents yourselves, agent
orchestration ranges from more
constrained architectures to
unconstrained architectures. Um
constrained is basically you kind of
more explicitly define the control flow.
Unconstrained is like a react loop,
function calling, codeact, whatever. you
basically give it a set of tools and let
it run. Um, deep research is kind of the
same thing.
Um, for us, we basically noticed there's
two main categories of UX's. Um, there's
more assistantbased UXs that can
basically surface information and um,
help a human surface information or
produce some unit of knowledge work
through usually a chatbased interface.
It's usually chat oriented. The inputs
natural language. Um, the architecture
is a little bit more unconstrained. you
know, it's basically a react loop over
some set of tools. Um, and it's
inherently both unconstrained but also
with a higher degree of human in the
loop. So the goal is or the expectation
is that the human is supposed to kind of
guide and coax the agent uh along the
steps of the process to basically
achieve the task at hand.
There's a I mean there's I'm sure many
of you have built these types of use
cases and so this is just a very small
subset um but it's basically just you
know your uh generalization of a of a
rag chatbot.
There's a second category of use cases
that I think is interesting and I think
a lot of folks are actually starting to
build more into this space which is um
this automation interface. So being able
to actually instead of uh providing some
assistant or co-pilot to help a human
get more information um processing
routine tasks in a multi-step end to end
manner and usually the architecture is a
little bit different. Um it takes in
some batch of inputs. Uh it can run in
the background or it could be triggered
ad hoc by the human. Um the architecture
is a little bit more constrained which
kind of makes sense right? If you want
this thing to run more end to end um you
need it to not just go off the rails.
Um, and there's usually a little bit
less human in the loop at every step of
the process and usually some sort of
like batch review in the end. And the
output is like structured results,
integration with APIs, uh, decision-m
after approval, it'll just go route to
the downstream systems.
Some of the use cases here include, you
know, financial data normalization, data
sheet extraction, invoice
reconciliation, contract view, and more.
Um, I'll skip this video, but you know,
there's some fun example of some
community- based open source repos we
built in this area, like the invoice
reconciler by Lori Boss.
a kind of general idea that we've emer
that has emerged and we've noticed as a
pattern is you know oftentimes the
automation agents can serve as a backend
because it runs in the background you
know can do the data ETL transformation
they're still human in the loop but it's
kind of the doing the thing where it
needs to process and structure a lot of
data um and do decisions in the
background and then assistant agents are
kind of more front-end facing right and
so automation agents can structure
process your data and provide the right
tool interfaces um for assistant agents.
Not every tool depends on agentic
reasoning, but for a lot of these use
cases like for a very generalized data
pipeline um where you're processing a
lot of unstructured context, you might
have automation agents go in and process
your data, provide the right tools for
some sort of more uh research userfacing
interface.
So we talked about building a document
toolbox. We talked about, you know, the
the different categories of agentic
architectures and putting it together.
Um, here are some real world use cases
of document agents. And these are
basically examples of agents that
actually help automate different types
of knowledge work. So, one of our
favorite examples is a combination of
both automation and assistant UXs for
financial due diligence. Um, Carl is one
of our uh favorite customers and and
partners. Um you know they basically
used uh some of the core capabilities
that we have to build an end toend
leverage bio agent um you know it
requires an automation interface to
inhale massive amounts of unstructured
public and private financial data um
Excel sheets PDFs powerpoints go through
some bespoke extraction algorithms with
human in the loop review and then once
that data is actually structured in the
right format providing a co-pilot
interface uh for the analyst teams to
actually both get insights and generate
reports over that data.
If you look at any enterprise search use
case that typically falls within the
assistant UX, um, SEMX is one of our
favorite uh, customers in this space
where, you know, just being able to
define a lot of different collections to
different sources of data and providing
more task specific specialized agentic
rag chat bots over your data, right? Um,
you know, it's basically rag, but you
add like an agentic reasoning layer on
top so that you can basically break down
user queries, do research, and answer
the question at hand.
And on the pure automation UX aside, uh
we notice a lot of kind of use cases
popping up around automate automation
and efficiency. And so one example is
actually technical data sheet injection.
Um you know, we're working with a global
electronics company. They have a lot of
data sheets that need to be
automatically processed and reviewed.
And historically, it's taken a lot of
human effort to actually do this. Um so
by creating the right end toend
automation agent you can basically
encode the business specific logic for
parsing these types of documents
extracting out the right pieces of
information matching it against specific
rules and outputting the structured data
into SQL. There's human in the loop
review. Um but if we're actually able to
do this end to end, it transforms weeks
of just like you know technical writer
work um into an automated extraction
interface.
So that's basically it. Um you know for
those of you who are less familiar,
Llama Index is the most accurate
customizable platform for automating
your document workflows with Adantic AI.
Um our mission statements evolved a
little bit since the past few years
where we're a very broad horizontal uh
framework oftentimes focused on rag. Um,
but if you're interested in some of the
capabilities, uh, come talk to us and
then please come check us out at Booth
G11. Thank you.
[Music]